with Cameron and Kentucky hey camera and
welcome to Dave Ramsey show hey how you
doing John right right what's up Cameron
how can we thanks for taking my call
so yesterday was actually my wife and I
it was our 3rd anniversary and so I
think this played out the way we played
years ago when I spoke to you today we
would have been out of baby steps to
button now so we've been doing a lot of
prayer and thinking over the past year
or two about what biblical marriage and
looks like for our family even before we
were married she want to be a
stay-at-home wife and mom which I
supported but you know I kind of wanted
us to be out of debt first when we're
still in baby step 2 but we're closer
you know to beam out of debt than when
we started but it's gonna come at some
expense of mental and emotional health
struggles with my wife and I in our
marriage and I'm took apart both to the
point where we're not wanting to
sacrifice those parts of her and our
marriage because it's just important so
you know if I could hear you guys
thoughts on that you know she's a
talented woman she wants to monetize
some things at home and we really have a
heart to be foster parents and you know
it's a mist of waiting for our own kids
that we can see but she's afraid to
leave her job right now so you don't
have you don't have children at home no
no - no kids yet
okay and so why is it she wants to be at
home so she wants to be at home desi
feels called in before marriage she felt
called to be a stay-at-home mother and
wife and to work from home and raise our
home and make our home you know keep the
home and raise kids and be able to work
from home things like that okay I
completely get that if there's kids
there I get it a less when they're not
just to be very blunt okay and I'm not
saying you're that that you know somehow
I'm not I'm not discounting the thing
I'm just saying I don't get it I cut as
well so what does she make so that's the
thing our her income has fluctuated
throughout our marriage it started at
like 32 then she dropped down to part
time it was only bringing home maybe
four or five hundred a month now she's
up at 39 for
okay so she's making 40 grand and what
do you make yeah I make 45 cuz she can
cut your household income in half for
her to be at home yeah Jeremy that
sounds like something else is going on -
is there something else besides just
this dream she's had to stay at home you
said something about mental health and
your relationship and how is that all
being broken down by her working I don't
understand normally doesn't destroy your
mental health in your relationships the
source or so she has to travel 30
minutes to work takes an hour far to get
home when she gets home she literally
has no energy to do anything you know
that a wife or a woman who takes care of
her husband or takes care of our house
once to do there's things I see must to
do this yes no energy to do she's you
know suffered from depression and are
you participating in the the run in the
house - I am as much as I can yeah okay
well to start with number one if the
only way that she can be well and avoid
depression is to be at home there's
probably other mental health things
going on okay because work does not
cause depression and being tired does
not cause depression depression causes
being tired but it doesn't work the
other way around so I would want to dig
into the root of which is what John was
doing there of what's really going on
and underneath if I were in your all
shoes for your own good if your wife
were ill in any way and her being at
home and working on half the income made
or not be ill in a heartbeat we'll
figure it out you know you work it out
you're just gonna be in debt longer your
baby step two is gonna take longer
because you cut your household income
and half your budgets gonna be a lot
tighter you're going to be below the
household income average household
income in America considerably on your
income alone so you've got to
investigate your options and your career
track and what you can do to get your
income up to offset that but I don't
want you to treat the symptom if there's
real problems with your wife I often
tell folks that the the
the biggest challenge about getting a
new job is that you go with you and so
my concern here is that when a change of
location a a reduction in work a change
in annex and why she's just gonna have
the same heart and the same challenges
just at home and so until like Dave said
until you really address what's going on
underneath that that that's just going
to follow you and John won't play pop
psychologist because this really
dangerous but the stuff that I've read
indicates and I don't know if it would
apply there or not but just as a general
statement that on that inactivity is a
gasoline on a fire
it hurts depression it doesn't help it
that's right activity helps it right
even exercise because it releases
proteins endorphins and adrenaline in
your body and simply helps you fight it
that's right and when you're working
with with patients with true clinical
depression
no it's little wins right they'll say I
want you today to get up and make shower
they didn't go back you can go back to
bed tomorrow and so yeah it's always
moving towards achieving goals solving
problems and being active and and really
to do put too fine a point on it to work
yeah Patsy Clermont does that in her
talk on fear she was Agra phobic and
homebound but by the fear and saying
open the door there yeah and she said
God she said I was laying in my bed
praying and I said God what do I need to
do why don't he did I'm tired of this
and God told her she said it real
clearly in my head I heard from God make
your bed and then she realized that
means I have to get out of it it's it's
a funny line and the way she delivers it
but it began her healing many many years
ago and she had been homebound by fear I
mean it was a big deal it's a huge thing
that she had overcome and it's a
wonderful testimony wonderful story but
that that one little step just what you
said I thought about that because I
always laughed she said I'm laying in
bed and he says make your bed that means
I got to do two things when I got to get
out of bed then I gotta make because I
can't make it while a minute and so yeah
there's looseness so activity you know
coming home to hide that's way felt and
I scares me a little bit it just feels
Cameron it feels I don't want to
discount what your wife's going through
I think the pain is real the challenges
the fear is real the yeah everybody
hates a 90 minute commute so that's all
real the other side of it is is you
always want to be running towards
something and working towards something
not running away from something and
stopping work to help with your mental
health issues I've never seen or heard
of that being effective unless she's in
an abusive situation or can can shift
and pivot to something else
yeah something to look at